oh i'm wrecking the set that's all right
it isn't worth much
it isn't worth much you guys how are you
yeah i'm great congratulations
that must be exciting you won an emmy
last night completely in shock
yeah because i was is dennis franz ellie
tomlin ed asner
rita moreno and i went and louis
anderson i went um
i better wear something colorful so at
least i'll be in a picture or something
because i
thought honest to god i didn't prepare
anything i just thought oh there's no
shot
right you just don't think that you
don't think you're going to beat those
people
no i wouldn't assume i was never going
to win anything but you run i want an
emmy yeah years and years ago i wanted
my work on hee haw which was highly
exciting i was junior
yeah we stood in the cornfield together
i remember
that hey conan
that's my favorite bit in the world by
the way well did you celebrate what did
you do last night you actually went and
got the big
spicy buffalo wings
you know everybody has their own way of
selling that's what you do you just went
crazy with the buffalo
i laid in them
i had the tub filled at the hotel
seriously a bunch of wings and the dip
was just put on me
and i'd grab one and drag it across me
and then eat it
fantastic that sounds really fun that
sounds very
very good it's just an individual thing
i would think there'd be various spots
on your body where that would be
unpleasant
spicy buffalo wings you know what my
navel will hold quite a bit of dip
[Laughter]
in fact there's still some in there for
later you never can have too much
the nice thing too because you won for a
show this this show is is based to some
extent
on your childhood yeah yeah i took out
all the horrible stuff
and just kept the humor uh-huh no i mean
my
my family was crazy my parents well you
come from a big family don't you
yes yes thanks for leaving out the crazy
part well i didn't have
no i come from one of uh six kids we
grew up in a pretty low but
you are one of 11. oh my god exactly
so there are like brothers and sisters
you haven't met yet who lives in the
house with you
who the hell are you mom
and uh so but it's weird because you
know that's a lot of people
11 is a lot 11 is way too many and
people always say you were your parents
catholic yeah and i always say no my dad
was a musician
which never gets a laugh but it's always
that little part afterwards yeah when i
say it never gets a lot
but i you know growing up in that kind
of family it's just what kind of you
what your dad was a little like what
kind of stuff
eccentric stuff was your dad you know
what he used to do is he was the kind of
guy who hated everybody yeah like he
would see somebody driving down
he'd be driving down the street and he'd
see somebody slow the car down go
look at that for crying out loud
[Laughter]
get my rifle
and he'd write hate mail he used to
write the president he used to write
hitman
he write the president hate mail and our
trick was
my mom would say our you kids mail it
and of course we were never supposed to
mail it
you were supposed to just give it to her
right and one time my brother mailed it
and the fbi or whoever that
group is cia i don't know secret service
thank you
you were originally going to be in the
secret service i was
i know i'm just here to enrich your
wordpress thank you thank you very much
so um so they come to the house and
we're all thinking good
take them you know yeah
here's the knife he was going to use
you're not trying to hide him go take
him and he's going to kill a lot of
other people too
could you get them out of here by friday
uh-huh so we could watch what we want on
the weekends
turn gun smoke on that's a good show
oh jesus wow well that's the mighty you
know that's the kind of
your parents your dad ran the tv set
when i was growing up i don't know about
you we weren't allowed to watch tv on a
school night
which was crazy but we would watch it
anyway and then our dad drove this beat
up station wagon that made a whistling
sound and we could hear the whistling
sound
so we would turn off the tv and run to
different rooms and pick up like books
and my dad would come in and he'd feel
for static electricity
on the front of it he's yeah he's like
columbo you know
and he would feel for static electricity
and then we would all be busted and so
would you get now what kind of what what
would happen like if you got busted what
was your punishment
they weren't good at sometimes they
would they always wanted to pretend that
they were going to like
oh we're going to get the belt out and
they were those people that just
couldn't quite do it so
they never actually hit you no your
punishment was to continue living in the
family
because that's the worst part isn't it
yeah yeah and you know what the worst
part is about families is when your best
friend comes over and you're leaving the
house and they go
your parents are so great
why what are you talking you're no
longer my
friend but you know
it's just fun you know families are all
wacked out yeah everybody tries to
put on a good show but it's all wackwill